president biden has his showdown with
vladimir putin and it doesn't go great
the federal reserve dramatically
increases its inflation estimate
and the left celebrates juneteenth
becoming a national holiday by decrying
america's supposedly unending racism i'm
ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let bigtech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben speaking of which have you ever used
incognito mode on your computer now you
probably thought because it's called
incognito mode well now you are
incognito right that's the entire name
of the mode
wrong you are the reality is that if you
check that fine print there's still a
bunch of people who can see
what it is that you are doing in fact
that fine print says your activity might
still be visible to your employer
your school or your isp it's weird that
they'd even call it incognito it's
really the truth to really stop people
from seeing the stuff
you visit you need to do what i do and
use expressvpn think about all the times
you've used wi-fi at a coffee shop a
hotel even at your parents house without
expressvpn
every site you visit could be logged by
the admin of that network that is still
true even when you're in incognito mode
what's more
your home internet provider can also see
and record your browsing data
in the united states they're legally
allowed to sell that data to advertisers
while expressvpn stops all that cold
expressvpn is an app that encrypts all
your network data and reroutes it
through a network of secure servers so
your private online activity stays just
that
private expressvpn works on all your
devices it is really really easy to use
you hit one button
on your phone once you have installed it
again installation takes like five
seconds and then once it's installed
hit one button you're protected stop
letting strangers invade your online
privacy today
protect yourself at expressvpn.com ben
use my link at expressvpn.com get three
extra months for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpns.com
to learn more alrighty so yesterday was
joe biden's big
face-off with vladimir putin and joe was
gonna stand tall and stand
strong against vladimir putin who you do
have to admire the guy's commitment to
being a bond villain
i mean truly the guy is a bond villain
it is it is astonishing
how much he is committed to that role he
is going to lower
sean connery over a tank filled with
sharks and there will be lasers attached
to their heads and
that is who vladimir putin is he is very
much committed to that image
in public meanwhile joe biden is
wandering around stumbling
into walls so this was all set up with
joe biden touting
just how strong and powerful he was
going to be now again there was no
reason to have this meeting
understand that usually when you have
bilateral meetings with people from
other countries unless they're allies
there's an agenda on the table stuff
that you want to accomplish stuff that
you're negotiating over
usually don't just get together for a
photo op because if you get together
with a
dictator for a photo op he is elevated
and you are naturally degraded
we are not answerable to russia we
should not be answerable
to russia russia has a gdp a total gdp
of 1.7 trillion us dollars in 2019.
okay do you understand that's their
total gdp that's not there that's not
like what they're spending on their
budget right we in the united states on
our federal budget
spend four trillion dollars a year and
maybe six if biden gets his way
the entire gross domestic product of the
country of russia is 1.7 trillion
dollars
they are not a world power they are not
a superpower they are a
decrepit declining power with heavy
military
and some aging nukes that is what russia
is it is a second rate power and the
fact that we continue to treat them as
though they are the ussr
is really quite astonishing how weak is
the
is the russian economy how weak is
russia as a country
i mean this is the reason why vladimir
putin is clinging to power right
their entire gdp is 1.7 trillion u.s
dollars
italy's gdp okay italy is is an economic
failure
because of its high tax rates and its
levels of corruption italy has serious
economic problems italy's gdp
is two trillion dollars germany's gdp
is 3.8 trillion dollars okay so if you
rank
gdp by country russia is
not close to the top of the list russia
is is
ranked 11th on the list
hey like the united states by contrast
our gdp on
a normal basis is almost 20 trillion
dollars a year
china's at like 12. japan's at 4.8
germany's at 3.7
india is a 2.6 the uk is at 2.6 france
brazil italy and canada all rank above
russia and south korea is right on their
heels
so russia is like when we when we
pretend that russia is a world power
russia is not a world power russia has a
less powerful economy
by a fairly large margin than brazil for
example
and we don't treat brazil with this kind
of kid glove
treatment we shouldn't treat russia with
the kid glove treatment but we have been
for years because we have this kind of
cold war mentality where russia is this
this aggressive world power that we
somehow have to negotiate with and
because
frankly too many european leaders are
and they want russian oil
i mean really the the german the german
government has been basically making
itself prone
to russian aggression and russian
leverage for years
okay in any case joe biden treating and
this is a bipartisan problem by the way
this is not just a joe biden problem
this is a problem for trump it was a
problem for bush it was a problem for
obama
like everybody has been treating russia
as this great world power when in fact
russia is not even close to a world
power
at this point in time in any case joe
biden says it's better to meet face to
face he can't really explain why we're
meeting face to face
or what he hopes to gain from eating
face to face vladimir putin is very
happy to meet face to face because for
him it's a win
he goes home and he plays all of the
clips of him chiding american media
about how terrible america is
and meanwhile the united states is
saying kind of mild critiques of how
putin runs his
dictatorial country and putin is
subjecting
his own dissonance to jail time and and
and
maybe death and the united states has
like mild
critiques and we think maybe we can work
with vladimir you know she's all just
business
there's a reason that dictators like
meeting with u.s presidents u.s
presidents should be very
very reluctant to meet with dictators
unless there's a real agenda on the
table like for example
an arms reduction treaty or something in
any case here was joe biden saying you
know it's better to meet face to face
and i hope that our meeting will be
productive
well thank you i said outside i think
it's always better okay well it's not
always better to meet face to face
particularly when your face
is an old daughtering codger who can't
really hold it together
this led to an unfortunate incident in
which joe biden yesterday was asked by a
reporter do you trust putin
do you trust each other this according
yamiche alcindor remember yamiche
alcindor
is just a lackey for the administration
right she works for pbs and she of
course
was a was a gadfly when it came to trump
but she is a bootlegger when it comes to
the abaddon administration just like
most of the media
and she tweeted this out after a
reporter asked biden do you trust putin
do you trust each other
biden looked directly at the reporter
and nodded affirmatively
that's jimmy schalcendor an ally of
president biden
and this was reported by a wide variety
of other media sources who were in the
room
all of which led shinsaki to immediately
respond before she'd even talked to
biden right she hadn't talked abiden
she immediately responded quote during a
chaotic free-for-all with members of the
press chatting questions over each other
the president gave a general head nod in
the direction of the media
he wasn't responding to any question or
anything other than the chaos oh is that
what happened
you know like before you actually spoke
with joe biden you know what was in his
head
okay the reality is that the biden team
treats him as an afterthought in their
own administration joe biden is not the
one making policy
joe biden is not the one in control of
us ronald mclean is chief of staff may
be in control of us
jake sullivan on foreign policy may be
in control of us joe biden has
very little control of this bus because
he is just not with us
we've already shown you tape where he is
walking around the g7 into random cafes
and then being led away
by the hand as though the woman is his
is his
care nurse and is dragging him away to
get his vitals tested
none of this is good right he's he's the
elected president of the united states
you don't want the president of the
united states
looking like a bewildered
a bewildered barely sentient patient
at an old age home on the world stage he
just doesn't look good
and for all those people who are
concerned about trump's optics this is a
very different sort of optics and it is
really not a good optics either
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first summer is here the days are
getting longer meaning you got some time
to check
all of the items on your checklist off
well here is an item
that you really should check out your
home and auto insurance you're probably
paying too much for your home and auto
insurance because you haven't bundled
them because you haven't chopped them
competitively because you got
home and auto insurance a long time ago
and you haven't re-looked at the rates
well now is a great time to head on over
to policy genius they make it easy to
compare home
and auto insurance all in one place they
can help you find home and auto coverage
similar to what you have now
but at a lower price they've saved
customers an average of 1
250 per year over what they were paying
for home and auto insurance as well
their team will handle the paperwork set
up your new policy switch over your
current one getting started is super
simple first you head on over to
policygenius.com
shapiro home and answer a few quick
questions about yourself and your
property
then policy genius takes it from there
they'll compare rates from america's top
insurers from progressive to allstate
and find you your lowest quotes on both
home
and auto insurance as well they can look
for ways to save you more they can
bundle your home and auto policies and
if they find a better rate than what
you're paying now they will switch you
over for free
their top-notch service has earned
policy genius an excellent rating on
trust pilot head on over to
www.policygenius.com
shapiro home to get started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and quite important to get it
right go check them out
right now alrighty so so after that
little mix-up
then joe biden he gave uh speech he gave
a couple of pressers the pressers were
not particularly long he answered like
four questions in one presser because he
just doesn't have
the sort of stamina that that other
world leaders have had
in the past or then vladimir putin had
yesterday
again if you're if you're going to have
this meeting and the meeting is about
optics then we do have to pay attention
to the
optics if the meeting is about substance
then we pay attention to the substance
but this entire meeting was about the
optics so joe biden decided for some odd
reason that he was going to hold his
presser outside it was apparently very
hot he started taking off his jacket in
the middle he was looking very tired
and he started mixing people up also he
mixed up trump and putin at one point
i caught part of presidents trump
putin's press conference and he talked
about the need for us to
be able to have some kind of modus
operandi where he dealt with
making sure the arctic was in fact a
free zone
okay so yeah again mixing up trump and
putin always a good look
also in terms of policy biden also said
that he gave
vladimir putin a list of 16 pieces of
critical infrastructure not to hit
now i have some questions about this
particular strategy
like my first question is why why is
that a good strategy
so you've got arch villain and you've
got
goldfinger over here sitting there
plotting things against the united
states
and joe biden rambles in and takes a
list out of his pocket he's like
i really like free to not hit these
particular
targets shout out to goosebumps they um
you just gave him a list of targets to
hit why would you do that
that doesn't make any sense it was joe
biden announcing that one
another we spent a great deal of time on
was cyber
and cyber security i talked about the
proposition that certain critical
infrastructure should be off
limits to attack period by cyber or any
other means i gave them a list
if i'm not mistaken i don't have it in
front of me 16
specific entities 16 defined
as critical infrastructure under u.s
policy
from the energy sector to our water
systems okay um
why like really why first of all you
think the russians don't know which
pieces of infrastructure are important
to us
second of all are there any consequences
attached to an attack on those pieces of
infrastructure third
do you really think the russians are
just going to openly attack it the game
that the russians have been playing for
a very long time in terms of cyber
security is they've been using proxy
cutout groups
and they use groups that are based not
in russia or they create
false sort of identification for groups
based in russia and then they attack
american sources and then they just deny
responsibility this is something that
that state
backed terror groups have been doing for
a very long time now iran has been doing
this
for decades and iran recognizes that if
iran were to attack american
soldiers directly then america might
hold iran responsible so instead they
set up some sort of proxy terror group
in iraq
or they set up a proxy terror group in
yemen or in brazil or wherever
and the same thing is through the
russians right they set up these sort of
proxy groups the proxy groups attacked
the united states and then russia just
disclaims
all responsibility and vladimir putin
throws oh what is this we've never seen
such a thing
right so you hand him a list of the
infrastructure you don't want the arch
villain to hit
brilliant move can't see how that one
backfires at all
then joe biden said that there will be
devastating consequences for
for russia if navalny dies now
understand the real purpose
the the true purpose of this particular
meeting was not to contrast joe biden
with vladimir putin
that was not the optic purpose again if
this is bad optics let's examine the
optic purpose the optic purpose for joe
biden and you can see it in the media
coverage was to contrast
joe biden with donald trump right that
was the optic purpose
and so that meant that joe biden's main
goal here
was to go out there and talk about the
wonders and glories of democracy
in putin's face basically and that's
wonderful but honestly like i have no
quarrel
with talking about how the united states
is superior to the
evil dictator of russia the murderous
dictator of russia like that seems like
a pretty easy win but does it forward
american interest in any material way
not really the media treated this as
though it was win simply because joe
biden said the word democracy over and
over again but did he actually leverage
anything out of vladimir putin
of course not because that was never the
agenda the agenda was simply to go there
and say a bunch of stuff and then leave
and then for the media to cheer joe
biden as though joe biden
is some sort of great world leader who
is leading the the
civiliza the civilized world into a
brighter future none of that is
happening
but he did get what he wanted which is a
bunch of headlines saying well at least
he's not trump
except for the fact that putin kind of
got what he wanted too
in fact in many ways putin got more than
what he wanted in any case here was joe
biden saying that
there will be devastating consequences
for russia if naval need eyes i don't
believe this is true
let me just put that out there right now
if alexander von diese i don't think the
united states is going to do much of
anything i think they'll up sanctions
on particular figures inside the russian
regime and i think that's about it
how do i know that because china took
over hong kong last year and no one did
anything
okay that was a lot worse than a latino
voluntary dying don't get me wrong
election of only
be a terrible thing and it would be
caused by the russian regime that tried
to have a murder
in the last couple of years as well but
the subjugation of seven
million citizens of hong kong to
complete chinese tyranny came at zero
cost for the chinese regime
i mean in fact the unleashing of a virus
that is killed now
at least three million people all over
the globe including six hundred thousand
americans
has come at zero cost for the chinese
regime i do not think that the west has
deterrent power against china and russia
anymore i think everybody knows it
including the chinese and the russians
and so i think that while the press is
cheering biden
i just don't think that there's any
reality this i think putin knows there's
no reality to this which is why he seems
so unflapped and so unbothered by any of
this here's joe biden
talking up the idea that there will be
serious consequences
i made it clear to him that i believe
the
the consequences of that would be
devastating
for russia i'll go back to the same
point what do you think happens
when he's saying it's not about hurting
the volunteers
all the stuff he says to rationalize
the treatment of navalny and then
he dies in prison i pointed out to him
that
it matters a great deal when a country
in fact and they asked me why i thought
it was important to
to continue to have problems with
the president of syria i said because
it's a violation international
norm yes this what what a strong and
unwavering
by the way this is one of the great laws
and it has been told in sort of
bipartisan fashion by presidents of both
parties and it's really really stupid
okay when joe biden says you know i
think that vladimir understands that it
wouldn't be in his interest to
you know lexington and baldwin
when he says that kind of stuff i'm
pretty sure that vladimir putin thinks
it's in his interest from the ball need
to die
and i really don't think he feels
particularly threatened he's been
playing this game for 20 years
he's been killing all of his political
opponents and garnering personal wealth
amounting to billions of dollars in
russia since like 1999
i i do not think that he sits around
every anything to himself
well i don't know is he my interest will
kill political opponent
i think mostly vladimir putin's
considerations are things like
why kill him with radioactive material
or push him out window
that's pretty much as far as the thought
goes for vladimir putin because again
the guys maintain power
for two decades there's this there's
this very self-flattering
western notion that everybody thinks
like we do they do not think like we do
by the way it is exactly this sort of
notion that leads to the ridiculous sort
of self-critiques of the west that you
see in the west
oh my god we're so racist we're so
terrible we're such an awful
unjust hierarchical society and anybody
who's spent any time outside of western
civilization
you know you you walk around planet
earth for like five seconds you're like
whoa america's pretty damned
unbelievable
i mean just incredible but because we in
the united states don't spend a lot of
time doing that
and because we think that everybody
thinks like we do like
but why can't we make peace with the
russians why can't we just
give give something away why can't we do
something
impo like why why why can't why doesn't
vlad like vlad probably understands
he probably gets it the same way we do
everybody thinks that
no they don't they absolutely 100 do not
the same exact
sort of foolish theory that democracy
can
be implanted anywhere and take root
immediately and be fine that led to the
notion that we were going to immediately
turn afghanistan and iraq
into thriving multicultural democracies
that exact same theory that was widely
disproved and scorned in the 2000s
is still applicable according to the
left for pretty much everything else
and well you know the russians they
probably think like we do i mean
vladimir putin that government they
probably think like we do so when
joe biden is saying himself even vlad
understands that that even
that he shouldn't do that no he
understands exactly what he wants to
understand which is how to keep power in
his country and amass personal wealth to
himself and
expand the borders of the the old soviet
union which he would like to
rebuild if he actually had the power to
do that and you can see this in vladimir
putin he's not hiding the ball
this is part of the problem with
watching this stuff with with a
weathered
eye when you watch these sorts of events
with any sort of knowledge of history
and you watch not biden but the other
guy it's not like he's hiding the ball
he's saying exactly what he wants and
what he plans on doing we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about how you make your business more
effective okay so let's talk for a
second about the power of text
so a lot of businesses they will call
people on the phone i get cold calls
i don't even pick them up i'm sure
that's true for you as well sometimes i
have a doctor's office they call me i
don't recognize the number
i don't pick it up but if that doctor's
office texts me and they tell me i have
an appointment i text right back you
know why because texting is really
effective it saves a lot of time
you need to make your business more text
savvy and that is why you need
podium podium makes doing business as
easy as sending a text because when
texts get opened
business gets done all your employees
can text from a single inbox offering a
smoother experience for your customers
you can answer questions or collect
reviews you can schedule appointments or
deliveries
you can do payment collection by just
sending a text card dealerships are
selling more cars by offering text
messages
one dealer just sold a 50 000 truck and
four text messages retailers
are increasing revenue by allowing
customers to shop via text message
even with stores open many people still
want to shop from home a jeweler just
sold a 5 000
ring with a few text messages even
coordinated curbside pickup with podium
again if your business and you haven't
tried texting
you really are missing out check out
podium today today's customers
expect on-demand everything even from
local businesses stay ahead of your
competition with podium
free plans for growing businesses plus
all the power growing businesses need to
scale
get started free today at podium.com
shapiro that is podium.com
shapiro okay meanwhile you got joe biden
saying oh yeah now the russians will
come around they'll come around
and meanwhile i kind of trust them and
also i trust them so much i gave them a
list of 16 pieces of infrastructure not
to hit
meanwhile vladimir putin and again
dedication to the bond villain role
tremendous here's vladimir putin
explaining a very um
uh a very nichian view of happiness this
is
this guy's read some russian literature
that's all you can say about vladimir
putin here we go
there is no happiness in life there's
only
a mirage of it on the horizon so you
know cherish that
it's hardly sort of you know family
trust but
uh i think there is a uh a spark of uh
hope in his eyes
he spark of open his eyes but understand
happiness is not a goal it is mere
journey
you'll always fall short and then fall
into irrevocable black pit of death
yeah i'll admit that i that i i sort of
enjoy that a little bit anyway
vladimir putin here's how he handled all
this right so meanwhile you have joe
biden he's like i think that vladimir
understands their cost to violating
human rights meanwhile
but vladimir putin was asked about
violating human rights and he's like you
know violates human rights you
you americans you violate human rights
here's vladimir putin
you have now prevented anyone who
supports him to run for office
so my question is mr president what are
you so afraid of once again
the u.s has passed a law
which said that the u.s
would uh particularly favor individual
organizations in russia and at the same
time they declared
the russian federation as an enemy
they publicly declared that they will
try to
contain russia my question is which
organizations which political
organizations
in the uh us uh are
going to be supported by the u.s
especially if they pay them okay and
then he continues along these lines just
starts ripping into america
and again this is the way that the ussr
used to act every time
anybody would point out that you know
they were serving millions of people in
ukraine for example
or that they were engaging in a
full-scale purge and murdering people
at the at the basement of the lubianca
by the tens of thousands anytime anybody
would mention this the uss i would
immediately come back with
yes and what about jim crow well this is
what vladimir putin is doing right now
on human rights
nothing but it still exists
because he starts going off on shootings
in the united states and he
he blames biden for shootings and
killings in the united states this is
the game for him
what did he get out of this optically
nobody seems to bother caring what putin
got out of it optically because the
media is so
fascinated by the idea that biden is
greater and better and more and more
pure than trump
what this was and should have been about
is depriving russia of a win but
they didn't deprive russia a win here's
vladimir putin talking about how biden
is responsible for shootings and
killings in the united states
you know in principle everything that
happened
in happens in our countries one way or
another
is the responsibility of the leaders
themselves look at the streets of
america every single day
there are shootings and killings
you you don't have time to open your
mouth and you're shot dead
what was that about who is responsible
for that
who are the murderers there okay so
there you have it now did vladimir putin
come with a win in just a second
we're going to talk about whether he did
like what were the actual material
takeaways
from this particular summit we'll get to
that in just one moment first
let's talk about the garbage that your
kids are being subjected to particularly
on tv we've talked the past several
weeks about children's television
cramming down all sorts of left-wing
social messages on your kids nickelodeon
featuring drag queens singing
to your children about transgenderism
like three to five-year-olds
yeah you might want an alternative and
this is where prageru
comes in prageru has now launched a
massive new k-12 grade education
program thousands of educators and
parents have already signed up
check it out at prageru.com forward
slash kids prageru has tons of free kids
shows books magazines with the
pro-american values that aren't being
taught in schools or most kids shows the
prageru website has everything you need
to get your young family through what's
happening in our country right now
do you want your kids to learn about our
nation's founding principles and be
proud of them how about passing on
values you care about like truth freedom
responsibility hard work equality
under god this is the stuff that prageru
is pushing to your kids
right now show your children their
animated shows books magazines most
importantly support prageru
in their efforts to take back america's
education subscribe now don't miss
prageru's incredible free kids content
we are basically a sister company with
prageru i love prageru
dennis and i are close friends and
prageru does an amazing amount of
terrific work on behalf of children
and adults go check them out right now
prageru.com forward slash kids today to
get better material
for your kids okay so how did this end
and well putin announced that they had
reached some sort of agreement on cyber
security which really means they haven't
reached an agreement on cyber security
as far as
cyber security is concerned we agreed
that we would begin
consultations on that issue and i
believe that's extraordinary important
okay so what exactly were the details of
that cyber security agreement
the answer is not much according to the
associated press which again was
cheerleading for biden throughout this
whole thing
u.s president joe biden and russia's
vladimir putin exchanged cordial words
and plotted modest steps on arms control
and diplomacy but emerged from their
much anticipated swiss summit wednesday
largely where they started
with deep differences on human rights
cyber attacks election interference and
more
the two leaders reached an important but
heartily relationship changing agreement
to return their chief diplomats to
moscow and washington
after they were called home as the
relationship deteriorated in recent
months
and biden and putin agreed to start
working on a plan to solidify their
country's last remaining treaty
limiting nuclear weapons but their three
hours of talks on the shores of lake
geneva left both men standing firmly in
the same positions they had started in
i'm not confident he'll change his
behavior biden said at a post-summit
news conference
what will change his behavior is the
rest of the world reacts to them and
they diminish their standing i'm not
confident
and meanwhile the white house and
kremlin had set low expectations going
into the summit they issued a joint
statement after the conclusion
that said that their meeting showed the
practical work our two countries can do
to advance our mutual interests and also
benefit the world okay so basically they
issued a statement
from miss congeniality right that's that
that's pretty much like they
world peace world peace
over and over biden defaulted to will
find out when assessing whether their
discussions about nuclear power cyber
security and other thorny issues
will pay off biden came into the summit
pushing putin to clamp down on the surge
of russian originated cyber security and
ransomware attacks
when the summit ended it wasn't evident
that more than superficial progress had
been made
biden said that he made clear that a
fresh across certain red lines his
administration would respond
and the consequences would be
devastating that was him talking about
navalny as we played before but um what
are those consequences nope
and meanwhile putin just continues to
deny it since most of cyber attacks in
the world are carried out from the cyber
realm of the united states
this is the game that he plays right
it's always the u.s the u.s is cyber
attacking itself that's that's probably
it
nailed it gary kasparov who's been a
long time
anti-putin dissident and he was on msnbc
and again msnbc they were busy
basically tubaning all over joe biden
for this thing right journalism all over
the wazoo hot sticky journalism getting
everywhere
but gary kasparov kind of burst the
bubble he was like uh yeah this was not
a win for joe biden
the good news the only good news about
the meeting about the summit it was
shorter than i expected
so there was not much damage done but
putin got what he wanted that's why he
was beaming with joy when he left uh
um uh press um the the summit and went
to the press conference even when he
entered
uh on these the building before the
talks he got the attention that uh
he couldn't couldn't be dreaming
of getting uh during the last few years
correct correct and kasparov knows more
about this than the entire
combined anchor staff at msnbc and cnn
that is for damn sure
meanwhile biden he walked out he said i
did what i came to do
he said the last thing he now who wants
now is a cold war we have significant
cyber capabilities and
and he knows it well actually the thing
that he wants most kind of is a cold war
because it actually enshrines his power
but this is the thing that's not the
message that you're gonna get from the
media today because the media are just
in the bag for biden as always this
whole thing was not directed
for foreign consumption it was not
directed at accomplishing anything it
was directed toward american consumption
that's all it was directed at an
american political audience
because biden knew that if he said a
couple of things like human rights and
democracy without actually demanding
anything of putin in terms of hard
deliverables
then the media would celebrate him and
say well at least he isn't trump and
that's exactly
what he got because this is our media
does that mean meanwhile i mean
it is incredible the media are being
treated just as just what they are they
are lap dogs biden pats them on the head
every so often
and he puts them outside when they are
being unpleasant they start barking he
immediately takes them and he pushes
them into the yard
and they they're just fine with it it's
absolutely incredible
so there was a clip that went viral a
little bit yesterday these reporters
who were outside their mikes were on and
they started joking about the kinds of
questions that they were going to be
asking
biden right before the summit
what did you think of the vice
president's trip
what are the questions they're joking
about where's hunter when is kamala
harris going to the border
and then they're joking about that
because they know that they're never
going to ask a difficult question of joe
biden
right they're they're literally joking
about wouldn't it be ridiculous if we
asked
why kamala harris isn't going to the
border it's just amazing meanwhile joe
biden
is treating the media exactly as they
wish to be treated in this bizarre s m
relationship
joe biden is he he's literally going
into press conferences and just reading
the stage directions
he's like they gave me a list of people
and i should call on because i don't
know faces
anymore or where i am there was the
president of the united states yesterday
in geneva
this is not about just our self-interest
it's about a mutual self-interest
i'll take your questions and as usual
folks they gave me a list
of the people i'm going to call on so uh
jonathan associated press
okay they gave me a list who is they
aren't you the most powerful man on
planet earth
who is they they gave you a list my
goodness
his handlers my goodness okay and then
he had this bizarre
sort of exchange with cnn's caitlyn
collins the way the media treated this
exchange
is really really telling so here was joe
biden yelling at cnn's caitlyn collins
like yelling at her here we go
why are you so confident he'll change
his behavior mr president
i did i'm not confident hey everybody
what are you doing
so when did i say i was compromised i
said
what i said was let's get it straight i
said what will change their behavior is
that the rest of the world reacts to
them and it diminishes
their standing in the world i'm not
confident of anything
i'm just stating the fact so how does
that account to a
constructive meeting as president
president putin you don't understand
that you're in your own business
if you don't understand that in the
wrong business now imagine that
president trump had said that to a
reporter a female reporter imagine that
a female reporter called out to him
and he had walked back and then started
chiding her and then finished with
you don't understand your own business
we would get a three week long news
cycle about sexism
the vicious brutal sexism of that
exchange we would get a long news cycle
about
attacks on a free press oh my god over
threat jim acosta would just be
slobbering all over himself as per his
usual arrangement
instead here's how cnn covered that
exchange okay remember caitlyn collins
is a reporter for cnn here's how cnn
covered that exchange
wolf it is quite striking to just see
the confidence in his
approach in his tone as he really
handles all of this he did not go
point by point rebutting uh everything
that vladimir putin said
there was a discussion among white house
aides what he should talk about but in
the end
he ended up talking about this press
conference essentially what he had
planned to going into it
he uh you know certainly was comfortable
in that moment taking off his jacket
answering these questions from some top
foreign policy reporters
in the audience that he doesn't always
call on
wolf as we assess this trip this is
why joe biden ran for president
unbelievable
i mean first of all i thought that cnn
had originally suspended jeffrey tubin
from masturbating on camera but
apparently you're allowed to do it so
long as so long as they let you
and it's um wow
wow guys so you have the president of
the united states attack your own
reporter
and you're too busy fapping to uh to
actually say a damn word about it well
done cnn by the way even biden later
recognized there was some blow back
online and biden was like
probably i should probably walk that
back a little bit so here's the truth is
joe biden is a combative jerk
okay people who have been following him
in the media for years know this he
treats the media like this
right he's very combat you saw on the
campaign trail he literally called the
guy fat on the campaign trail when the
guy asked him a tough question he's like
listen up
fat remember that one that is actually
who joe biden is he's not this genteel
elderly statesman he's an idiot he's
been an idiot for 40 years
he's a loudmouth braggart dumbass and
and like the the fact that we treat our
politicians this way is truly incredible
to me and the fact that the media treat
the politicians
who who like they only like them when
they get what they want from the media
obviously
my favorite tweet of yesterday there was
a there's a journalist and i'm trying to
remember which one
who tweeted yesterday joe biden just
said that journalists are the smartest
people he knows
donald trump never said anything like
that yeah because it's not true
journalists are not the smartest people
i know are you out of your mind i work
with journalists every day
some of them are smart some that are
some of them are dumb as rocks
the hell are you talking about the
smartest people i know are
mathematicians
doctors phds in actual hard sciences not
like in education
like what what but the media are like oh
my god
oh it's like when harry met sally out
here for the media oh he said we're
smart oh
oh oh i'll have what they're having
and what in the what in the actual world
so here's joe biden walking that back he
knows where his bread is buttered too
which is as long as he continues to
massage the media every so often they
will continue to uh
to release his chakras
look to be a good reporter you got to be
negative you gotta have a negative view
of life
okay it seems to me the way you are you
never ask a positive question why in
fact
having agreement we'll find out the
thing that always amazed me about the
questions
and i apologize for having been sure
if you were in my position would you say
well i don't think man anything's gonna
happen it's gonna be really real
i think it's gonna really be bad you
guarantee nothing happens
okay first of all it's the stupidest
answer i've ever heard no you should be
honest you should say
i am highly skeptical that we are going
to get any sort of
concession from the russian government
absent serious international pressure
which is why i'm calling for a
ratcheting up of serious international
pressure
instead it's like no i'm hopeful that
we'll get something yeah good luck with
that good luck with that
alrighty in just a second we'll get to
all of the experts
it turns out their expertise not so
expert when it comes to the economy
we'll get to that momentarily first
let us talk about a magnificent
meaningful gift
okay so father's day is of course coming
up i'll tell you what make a great
belated father's day gift
paintyourlife.com so over our couch we
have hanging
a beautiful portrait of our family in
fact we have to get a new one made
that's uh that includes the squishy baby
but
paint your life takes pictures and then
they turn them into these beautiful
portraits that you can hang
on your wall they're just spectacular
you get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo
at a truly affordable price you can
choose from a team of world-class
artists and work with them until
every detail is perfect the
user-friendly platform lets you order a
custom-made hand-painted portrait in
less than five minutes
you can send any picture yourself your
kids family a special place a cherished
pet or
combine photos into one painting it
makes the perfect birthday anniversary
wedding gift it is meaningful
it is personal it can be cherished
forever at paintyourlife.com there's no
risk if you don't love the final
painting your money is refunded
guaranteed right now is a limited time
offering get 20
off your painting that is right 20 off
and
free shipping to get the special offer
text the word ben to 64
000 that has been to 64 000 text my name
ben to 64 000 paint your life celebrate
the moments that matter most term supply
available at paintyourlife.com text ben
to 64 000. alrighty in just a second
we'll get to the latest economic reports
surprise surprise the experts blew it
who could have predicted such a thing
it gets that momentarily first as you
know american values are under assault
right now like your individual rights
and you can feel it
right you see it every day and talk in a
few minutes about some stories of people
just
seeing their individual rights stripped
from them because every major
institution in american life
has been renormalized and weaponized by
the left against these rights
it's why i wrote the book the
authoritarian moment to help understand
how all of these institutions from
education
science got taken over by the left
re-normalized and weaponized
against you and your rights and what the
book really is about is how we fight
back against that
what steps do we need to take in order
to reverse the progress that the left
has made in taking over these
institutions
and emptying them out of any content and
then using them purely as weapons
arm yourself with the knowledge you need
to shut the wok cult down in its tracks
before it is too late
the authoritarian moment i think it's a
really important book it is now
available for pre-order at amazon barnes
noble or any other
major bookseller go check it out once
again it's called the authoritarian
moment
it's already sold thousands and
thousands and thousands of copies get
yours
right now on pre-order at any bookseller
including amazon
meanwhile no one ever said leaving a
cult was easy every now and then
somebody actually does it if they didn't
we'd never get an inside glance into
just how disturbing the ideologies they
push really are
that's why we should all be listening to
georgia howe's brand new podcast office
hours
here at daily wire georgia is a former
liberal and school teacher she became
aware of the ideological indoctrination
spreading throughout the school system
she took a stand against it in her viral
walk away video
now on her podcast she gets into
everything from critical race theory to
transgenderism with various experts the
media will not allow you to hear she
offers a wealth of incredible
information from some of america's most
important voices
subscribe and download office hours with
georgia howe on apple podcast or
whatever your platform of choice may be
get ready for the ultimate listening
experience
no matter where you are also we have
another exciting announcement for you
today and yet another reason to join the
daily wire
the left loves to quote unquote amplify
black voices but only when those voices
repeat exactly what the left wants
that's why it was not a big surprise
that during black history month amazon
removed
created equal a documentary about
clarence thomas's rise from the
segregated south to the highest court
in america and the all-out war that was
waged on him by the left during his
confirmation hearing so amazon took that
documentary
down like in the middle of black history
month now it's unfortunate that amazon
deep platform
such an excellent and it was actually a
really high performing documentary
but the daily wire has gained from that
because right now the daily wear has
acquired
the north american streaming rights two
created equal so
get ready it's a really important film
it's a really important documentary
about one of the most important figures
in modern american history clarence
thomas is streaming
live tomorrow 9 p.m eastern 8 p.m
central
for all daily wire members over at
dailywire.com if you're not yet a
dailyworm member you can join with
codejustice for 20 off your membership
get ready to start streaming
today take a look at the trailer i was
never going to be white
the problem is i could never go back
completely to the world i came from
[Music]
i saw what i had become i did not ask
god that if you take
anger out of my heart i'll never hate
again you're not really black because
you're not doing what we expect black
people to do
that's when all heck broke loose so
you'd still like to serve on the supreme
court
i'd rather die than withdraw from the
process
[Music]
so once again you can stream created
equal tomorrow live at 9 00 pm eastern 8
pm central at dailywire.com if you're
not yet a daily wire member join with
codejustice for 20
off your membership and get this amazing
clearance thomas documentary and
all of our other fantastic content like
run hide fight
or our talk show candace or the second
hour of this show
on demand go check it out right now
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty meanwhile the federal reserve
it turns out that the experts oh they
were wrong
wait you mean you mean experts are wrong
sometimes i know
after a year in which they're wrong
about nearly everything it turns out
they've been wrong on the economy as
well
according to ben zeiss loft reporting
for the daily wire
the federal reserve hiked its inflation
expectations while not backing down from
aggressive monetary stimulus which makes
perfect sense
you're completely acknowledging that you
got wrong your inflation
recommendations and then you're just
holding to the same policy
genius the central bank insisted during
its much anticipated june meeting
inflation is transitory in nature as the
united states emerges from coven 19 and
the lockdown induced recession
although the federal open market
committee intends to aim for stable
inflation rates in the long term
term it increased inflation projections
for 2021
to 3.4 percent an entire percentage
point higher than its march forecast
the fed's statement reads quote the
committee seeks to achieve
maximum employment and inflation at a
rate of two percent over the long run
with inflation having run persistently
below this longer run goal the committee
will aim to achieve inflation moderately
above two percent for some time
so that inflation averages two percent
over time and longer term inflation
expectations remain well anchored at two
percent
the committee expects to maintain an
accommodative stance of monetary policy
until these outcomes are achieved so in
other words because
there was deflation last year because
demand fell off because all the
businesses were closed and all of the
rest of it
because of that they're now saying well
if we run you know four percent
inflation five percent six percent
inflation year on year
well we can do that for a while and
it'll all average out in the end
yeah except for if it starts to run out
of control it's gonna be kind of harder
to control it on the other end without
some pretty significant
economic ramifications when you raise
those interest rates why would you not
be gradually raising interest rates
right now there's no shortage of credit
in the american system right now
right now in fact we're just paying
people to stay home
meanwhile the fed will continue to
promote a near zero interest rate and
purchase
treasury bonds in order to inflate the
currency the committee decided to keep
the target range for the fed funds rate
at zero to one point four
to one quarter percent and expects it
will be appropriate to maintain that
target range
until labor market conditions have
reached levels consistent with the
committee's assessment
of maximum employment and inflation has
risen to two percent and is on track to
moderately exceed two percent for some
time so to understand what they are
doing right now you have to understand
that basically what the fed funds rate
does
is it sets the overnight lending rate
between banks basically you have all of
these banks
and at the end of the day their balance
sheets have to live
up to what they promise right they have
to hold a certain amount of money
in the back room in case people come to
the bank and they want the money because
when you give your money to the bank the
bank doesn't normally hold it there it
lends it out
okay so these banks lend to each other
at an overnight rate so if i have a
surplus of cash and another bank needs
cash and it's back room
i lend to that bank and there's a
there's a rate the overnight
markets rate that sets what that rate is
when the fed sets its rate at zero
basically it makes it very very easy
for banks to take out credit from the
fed funds
okay not just that when the fed funds
decide that they want to inject
money when the federal reserve decides
he wants to inject money into the system
the way it does this is the treasury
department issues a bond
okay then let's say goldman sachs buys
the bond from the treasury department
and then resells it to the federal
reserve which literally just makes up
money in order to buy it the federal
reserve doesn't take money that's
already there the federal reserve just
adds a zero to its ledger
at the end of a big number and then it
just buys a bunch of bonds and then
that fake money which is digital becomes
real money
in the hands of these bond traders and
then these banks and these institutional
investors are supposed to take that
money
and they're supposed to invest in and
this is supposed to jog the economy well
what if people
aren't leveraging up right now because
there is just not the demand
what if people have stopped leveraging
up because no matter how much they
leverage up they're not able
to actually get workers to come back in
the workforce because we are paying them
to stay out of the workforce
then you have inflation because you have
too much money chasing too little
product and that's exactly what we are
seeing
right now and the fed has upgraded
expectations of america's real gdp
growth from 6.5
to 7 percent in 2021 it made no changes
to its forecast
of a 4.5 near term unemployment rate the
fed is also going to extend its
temporary us dollar liquidity swap lines
with nine central banks through december
31st
2021 in order to promote the supply of
credit to households and businesses both
domestically
and abroad again we are seeing the worst
increase in inflation since the great
recession
the consumer price index saw a five
percent year-over-year increase but the
producer price index a metric
metric that tracks businesses purchasing
costs reach a 6.6
year-over-year increase i've been
talking to people particularly in the
construction industry here in florida
they're telling me they cannot get
materials
they're telling me that the materials
they are getting are extremely expensive
and most of all they're saying they
literally cannot find labor
that people are not willing to work
right now because the government is just
paying them to stay home
so genius stuff happening from our
federal government
as always meanwhile controversy breaking
out
oddly enough mainly from the left over
juneteenth so yesterday
congress adopted pretty much unanimously
there are a few people who voted against
it
to make juneteenth a national federal
holiday now juneteenth
is the date in which slaves in texas
were finally informed about the
emancipation proclamation
and it happened like two years after the
emancipation proclamation and so it's
been celebrated in black communities
around
the united states as sort of the marking
the end the date marking the end of
slavery
for decades truly decades and so now
it's been made a federal holiday and as
i said yesterday on the program not only
do i not have a problem with this
i think that it's quite good that we
have a federal holiday marking the end
of slavery
because that was a signal moment in
america's history
it seems to me that we should absolutely
celebrate the end of slavery
whether that should be on juneteenth or
whether that should be upon the
ratification of the 13th and 14th
amendments to the united states
constitution
the the revivification of the promises
of the declaration of independence
under the auspices of the lincoln
administration and the end of slavery
and the establishment of equality before
law at least
in at least in the constitution and then
gradually effectuated over time
so that now there is full equality
before law in the united states and if
you don't believe that you should read
some of the laws of the united states
sometime
that is well worth celebrating that is a
very good thing now what the left was
saying is that they want juneteenth
to be made a federal law so that we can
basically club americans
by saying that if they don't now agree
with our racial agenda then
it's because they don't understand the
legacy of juneteenth the legacy of
juneteenth is racial progress right it
is literally marking racial progress in
the united states
and there's been a lot more racial
progress as it turns out between 1865
and 2021.
okay so it seems that that should be a
date that frankly everybody should
celebrate right i mean that's a very
very good thing that slavery ends in the
united states this is undisputed
him but the left is is using this as an
excuse as they always do everything is
an excuse to push for more
always so you have a person named steed
herndon
okay at a steed wesley on twitter he's a
national political reporter based in new
york for the new york times
he's a reporter not an opinion guy and
he is very upset
that juneteenth became a national
holiday yesterday and voted nearly
unanimously
unanimously in the senate with like
total support from everyone
he says that what's what's truly amazing
is that many of the same people who are
voting to make juneteenth the national
holiday
also oppose critical race theory a
critical race theory is not
guaranteed critical race theory is the
belief that all of america's
institutions
are irrevocably intertwined with racism
that they are shot through with racism
that they are so poisoned at the root
that all of the branches are just fruit
of the poisonous tree
that is the basic idea of critical race
theory that whiteness
is is present in everything that racism
is a normal state of the world
that people don't even acknowledge their
own racism and that people benefit
from that racism okay and that kids are
supposed to be taught this
now here's the reactant so what did this
guy tweet out what did this reporter
this national political reporter st
herndon tweet out for the new york times
quote it's kind of amazing
juneteenth is going to be a federal
holiday for reasons teachers won't be
allowed to explain to their students out
of fear or critical race theory backlash
um what i'm pretty sure americans know
about slavery
turns out that we were all literally all
of us taught about slavery in school
from the time we were children
we are all very much aware of slavery
and that's why juneteenth is a national
holiday to end slavery but notice how
the left conflates all the issues right
all the issues are the same
always and forever all of them
and if you if you apparently quote
unquote give the left an incident i
don't think this is giving the left an
inch i don't think it's giving them
anything frankly to celebrate the end of
slavery again i think that's a pretty
unifying thing
but if you give them what they perceive
to be an inch they then proceed to try
and take it for a mile
and that mile is indoctrinating your
children in the idea that america's
institutions are irrevocably racist
which by the way is the precise reverse
of what juneteenth is juneteenth is a
recognition that america's institutions
changed and morphed and molded and
adapted
in order to be less racist right
the reality is the constitutional
provisions for amendment were utilized
in order to end slavery in the united
states
the reality is that it was america's
legal process
that was changed by the law under the
systems and institutions of the united
states
in order to effectuate the end of
legalized racism in the united states so
actually celebrating juneteenth
is precisely counter to critical race
theory which suggests
i mean derek bell openly suggested this
that racism in the united states has
gotten worse
not better juneteenth is a precise
rebuke and rebuttal of that idea but the
media have decided
that basically you have to accept if you
are racially sensitive you have to
accept that america's a more racist
place a more terrible place and you have
to allow the indoctrination of your
children
in this particular idea that is of
course absolute stupidity
there's a reason why there's a backlash
and that backlash is going to be
extremely strong
i am perfectly willing and so is every
other american i know to hear about the
flaws of the united states what i'm not
willing to hear
is that the united states is at root a
racist horrifying country and our
institutions are bad
that is not true it's a patent and
absurd lie
on its face and the people pushing it
have nothing but malignant intentions
for what comes next year
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon
is the matt wall show it airs at 1 30
p.m eastern today
matt explores the massive bisexual
versus pansexual
dispute bisexual means apparently that
you like people of both sexes pansexual
means that you like
like kitchenware so be sure to check it
out over at dailywire.com
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wiedowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the mat wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show